hello my name is Eric challenger
director the UCSF centered for Vance
technology in this video I'll show you
how to use magnetic purification beads
commonly referred to as am pure or spry
beads that are commonly used in
next-generation sequencing library
preparation these beads are magnetic
particles that are carboxy coated and
contain and are in a solution that
contains Pei and sodium chloride the
pegan sodium chloride costs nucleic
acids to precipitate out a solution and
use the beads as a nucleation points and
once they're stuck on the beads they can
be manipulated with magnets what's nice
about these Frye beads is that they can
be tuned so that you can get different
sizes of nucleic acids binding the beads
by the ratio of this peg solution that's
added so a lot of these purification are
typically done in PCR tubes and small
magnets like this but for the purpose of
today's video we'll be using eppendorf
tubes because they're a little bit
easier to visualize and this larger
magnets the first step is to take your
sample and add some of the Spry beads to
the sample when pipetting the Spry beads
you want to pipette slowly because the
solution is very viscous to the high pay
concentration
when he add the mixture to your sample
you can mix by pipetting up and down or
you can vortex you just want to make
sure you get a nice homogeneous
suspension and if he vortex you want to
give it a quick spin in a benchtop
centrifuge just to collect all the
fluids to the bottom up it's you will
want to let the beads sit and the
solution to sit for about five minutes
at room temperature to give to nucleic
acids time to bind to the surface of the
beats so now five minutes at the laps
and we'll put the sample onto the
magnetic rack depending on the strength
of your magnet and the volume of beads
that you've used this can take anywhere
from two minutes to five minutes for the
beads which now contain the nucleic
acids to move to the back of the tube
attracted to the magnets you'll know
this is complete when your solution is
clear and all the beads been pulled out
of solution
now several minutes have elapsed and if
you can see the beats are now stuck to
the back of the tube and in nucleic
acids that are stuck onto the beats are
also been pulled out of solution the
next step is to remove the supernatant
which now contains do not contain any of
your sample when you remove the
supernatant be careful not to disturb
the beads at the back of the tube you
can discard the supernatant and perform
the first wash of with 80% ethanol some
protocols may call for a different
percentage of ethanol
so just consults your protocol when you
add the ethanol wash you want to be
careful not to disturb the pellet so
you're not risa spending the beads or
mixing them in solution you're simply
just adding ethanol to the tube while
the beats are still stuck to the back of
the tube this is used to route wash out
any of the residual salt and PEG present
around the beads you want to let this
sit for 30 seconds after 30 seconds of
elapsed remove the first wash
and then add the second ethanol wash to
the tubes again making sure you don't
disturb the pellets 30 seconds at
elapsed and we'll remove the second wash
try to remove all the residual ethanol
from the bottom of the tube to a drying
now you want to let the beads dry for
about five minutes at room temperature
this allows the excess ethanol there's
still present on the beef to evaporate
away and depending on the volume the
beads that you use and the size of your
tube sometime this drying might happen
faster during the Sun if you notice the
beads are starting to get dry and not
glistening anymore that's an indication
that the beads are fully dry and it's
ready to go into illusion so if you see
them starting to turn this kind of a dry
cakey brown color you'll want to pull up
off the magnet and go directly to
elution five minutes have elapsed and
now we'll resuspend the beads with our
elution buffer elution buffer Sibley are
just water or a low concentration of
Tris or Tris EDTA so they don't contain
high concentrations of salts or peg and
this causes DNA that's present on the
beads to be spend back into solution and
so we'll do is make sure we re spend the
beads and get rid of any chunks and
break them up and you can do this by
pipetting up and down or you can vortex
at the vortex just make sure to do a
quick spin afterwards to collect the
liquid at the bottom of the tube and
we'll let this sit for 30 seconds to
give the nucleic acids a little bit more
time to come off the bees and into
solution after 30 seconds of elapsed
place the tube back on the rack to pull
the beads that now do not contain
nucleic acids out of solution leaving
the nucleic acids in your sample in the
solution
so the second bead bonding step to the
magnet actually occurs a lot faster
because our loosened buffer doesn't
paint peg which is very viscous so in
the initial separation it took several
minutes because of the high
concentration to peg slowed the movement
of beads towards the magnets and you can
see already our beads are stuck to the
back of the tube and we're ready to pull
off our le wigs you want to carefully
remove your sample and again not disturb
the bead pellet at the back if you
notice that you've pulled up some beads
it's okay just go ahead and put your
sample back in the tube and let the
sample sit for a few seconds to allow
the beads to stick back to the magnets
so now our le wit with our purified
sample is now in our new tube and we've
completed our cleanup thanks for
watching
you